اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في عدد جديد من
برنامجكم برنامج حوار نستضيف فيه اليوم
رئيس احد اعرق الانديه الجزائريه لكره
القدم احد الفرق الاكثر تتويجا في الجزائر
فريق له تاريخ كبير وقاعده جماهيريه واسعه
فريق عرفه كيف يسيطر على الكره الجزائريه
في المواسم الثلاث الاخيره وتوج بطل لها
من دون منافس اسعد اليوم واتشرف باستضافه
محمد الحاج رئيس نادي شباب بلوزداد
الجزائري مساء الخير سيدي الرئيس
الاول والملف الاول على الملعب الراقي
قلتم انكم قدمتم ملف ثقيل من اجل
الاستفاده من هذا الملعب هل لنا نعرف بعض
التفاصيل
نبغى ولكنه عند اللي يهمهم العمر ممكن
نزيدو ونعاون ونديروا
شويه بتعرف الخدمه
المدروس
يهدرك باسوان
الفئات المختلفه والتي تعدل ربما مصدر
المستقبل
هم يكونوا في نفس المكان على كل حال
وتدريب والفندق
[موسيقى]
الملعب دونك فيها تخمام هذا غلط وكنت غلط
المشاكل لسيد الرئيس
شباب مشاكل
بزاف ويعني ونكونوا بسيسه سيدنا خضرنا
ونقول
له وقال له رحت روحه والسلام عليكم
ومبروك عليك
الدراهم كثير كثير كثير كان شخص واحد طالب
29 مليار
نحن
الاخطار النار
[موسيقى]
كان راح يسموه
معروف في اللي كان نروح احتل اليوم في في
الكوميديا تاثير
ممكن ممكن
جديد جديد
بصراحه
اكثر منه بنكمل يعني
اكيد
عقد جديد وقعت عليه امس
ما هذا العقد الذي يخص التسويق صوره
الفريق
اسبانيول اسبانيول
اللوكانده
اول اول
انتدابات
على صوره بالخادم الذي بامكانه في همم
القاطره الاماميه يا شباب
هذا الموضوع تكلمت عليها انا ما يخصنيش
انا انا سرحت بالليل كلها ومسؤولين تاعه
وكلها متحمله اوكي
[موسيقى]
كلمت عليهم
يعني موافق بهذا الشيء ممكن في المستقبل
ان شاء الله الشبان
شويه بشويه
البطوله المواسم الماضيه لكن الجميع متى
يكون قميص شباب بنجمه الكاس الافريقيه
الفضائيه شباب
[موسيقى]
اشوف مشروع
احنا شباب
كله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله هل خطرنا في
الرنه في المفاوضات مع العيد
متى يكون التفسير شوف لي تشوف همم
لنوفل ميتورنا
التبانيهم وفومات
ان شاء الله نتمنى تكون في اقرب وقت
المضرب هذاك قطعه الارضيه
الشديد وباجابه بنعم او لا قيل ان علاقتك
مع شرف الدين عماره تدهورت في الاونه
الاخيره هل هذا صحيح
هو هو رئيس المجمع
[موسيقى]
سيد محمد
في اشهر قليله من كسب قلوب انصار النادي
اصبحت محبوب الجماهير في شباب بلوزداد
شكرا جزيلا لك على قبول هذه الدعوه
وعلى الارض الاسئله
شكرا بارك الله فيك شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
معلومات تتدفق باستمرار
نحن هنا لنقف على كل المواضيع ملتزمين
بالتدقيق والتحقق في الميدان وفي كل
الظروف من استشرف المستقبل عبر فهم الحاضر
نحن معكم على مدار الساعه كل يوم
[موسيقى]